i i know what about about of course your
your former teammate garrett gareth
southgate i mean thinking back to
sitting alongside him in the dressing
room back in 1996.
did you ever think that that player that
you know that you
played alongside would ever end up
managing first of all then managing the
national side and then managing the
national side
all the way to a major final
do you know what new i would always say
he was always a sensible one
in that 96 squad but that wasn't hard if
i'm honest
um he was always the one that you know
he he always managed to you know he was
a he's certainly a thinking man
not necessarily more than anybody else
but he wouldn't you know he put his way
he wasn't in a dentist chair he was one
of the players that would
stay behind and and was pretty sensible
gareth was a
great trainer you know good footballer
he knew his strengths knew his
limitations
but was always you know a thinking man i
think that's why he's done so well with
his squad
you know he's lucky he's got some really
really good young players because damara
could have managed you off you haven't
got the tools to work with you've got no
chance
and i think he's this is a really strong
generation of players a lot of good
young players that are
wanting to learn i think we also have to
give a lot of respect and
and almost a bit of gratitude to the
manager the managers that these players
are working with
a lot of them work every day with pep
guardiola thomas tucker
and managers that have had so much
success so they're learning if you like
from some of the best coaches in the
world so gareth is getting them you know
he's like reaping the rewards if you
like so we are very lucky that we've got
this group of players but we've also got
a manager that's so calm and sound of
mind that he knows what he's doing
he surprised me of how strong he's been
some of the decisions he's made and some
of the teams he's picked i would never
have picked him
never and i think you could ask a lot of
football people that know the game
inside out
so you have to say yep you've got
everything right so far so fingers
crossed you can do that again in the
final
you